i want to start today with something
that's kind of
really good news
uh some in the audience have grown
increasingly frustrated with me
that i have not really
put out my sense of a way to
radically
deprogram right-wing extremists and
reactionaries from
uh fact-free trumpism or ignorant
political ideas call it what you will
but the question that we've been kind of
grappling with is okay great tens of
millions of people think trump actually
won they would vote for him again they
believe
untrue things about vaccines and climate
change and the pandemic and all these
different things great we've identified
a problem how do we fix it and at the
individual level we know well you know
if you spend three hours six hours with
individuals you can change some minds
but that's a really difficult thing to
do at a sort of large scale
at the same time when we think about
something from above that radically and
quickly changes views uh we're often
talking about significant
authoritarianism which is a progressive
i am against authoritarianism so we
don't really have an answer but we we
now have a new study
that is
really inspiring and reassuring that it
is possible although what we can
actually do as a result remains a
question mark so i'm talking about um a
a incredible new study called the
manifold effects of partisan media on
viewers beliefs and attitudes a field
experiment with fox news viewers and
there's a good write up of what this did
uh and essentially what they did is they
took fox news viewers and they paid them
they paid them
to watch cnn for 30 days and what they
found was that after watching cnn for 30
days
the fox news viewers became more
skeptical about fake actual fake news
less likely to buy into fake news
and they also found changes in attitudes
and policy preferences on covid19
on evaluations of then president trump
and of republican candidates and they
wrote and this is so
not incredible but but it's a good thing
despite regular fox news viewers being
largely strong partisans we found
manifold effects of changing the slant
of their media diets on their factual
beliefs
attitudes
perceptions of issues importance and
overall political views
they write it found that fox news gave
viewers information about why the
disease is not a serious threat while
cnn provided more information about the
disease itself this changed people's
views and it goes on and it says a lot
more about what was done here and this
is important for so many different
reasons now obviously
if you think cnn is bad and not
trustworthy on the facts then you would
see this as bad you would say wow they
they believe the right things when they
watch fox news
and after 30 days of watching cnn all of
a sudden they believe all these liberal
lies now on these particular issues we
know during the pandemic when trump was
president fox news was giving a very
skewed perspective of the pandemic and
about other issues so you can argue as
to whether it's a good thing or not that
they end up believing what they see on
cnn rather than what they see on fox but
that's not the issue i want to focus in
on
the incredible good news is
if we put the right information in front
of people we can debate what the right
information is but if we put the right
information if we put accurate
information in front of people
their beliefs
are not as resistant to revision as we
might have thought
and
the other kind of scary aspect of this
is it reminds us of the significant
impact of one's media diet
it's incredible or maybe not maybe we
say it's disturbing
what happens to people's beliefs when
their media diet is restricted to what
we might call extremist media or
disinformation media and to some extent
i will gladly concede that cnn
profits off of
and
depends on
fear-mongering salacious stories the
kind of if it bleeds it leads the most
extremist and hyperbolic interpretation
of things with a different perspective
than fox news but cnn is nowhere near as
dishonest we have to understand the kind
of corporate fear leads framing um
when i was on my flight to las vegas in
fact
there was a guy sitting across the aisle
from me and i it's a long flight from
the east coast five and a half six hours
i watched him consume hours of fox news
but then later in the flight i looked
over and msnbc was on
and
it was interesting because i was reading
this study on the flight as i was
watching this guy
and we might
wrongly say well the msnbc is going to
have no impact on the guy and what the
study shows is that it does now again
msnbc
is a not as
dishonest
editorially liberal corporate media
outlet so for me msnbc is not exactly
the solution to fox news and what this
gets me back to is
many people are kind of addicted to
outrage
fear
anger and validation of their existing
views as well because the anger gives
people sometimes what is like a
temporary relief from what are maybe
more difficult feelings to deal with you
know despair in their lives or a feeling
of helpless helplessness or whatever the
case may be conspiracy content as we've
talked about before is sometimes
soothing to people because they would
rather believe everything is planned and
orchestrated rather than there are
random bad events that we really can't
predict specifically and so my main
takeaway from this study is the great
news is
people's beliefs aren't as resistant to
revision as we thought
if we put the right content in front of
them but the most important takeaway for
me is
i don't really want
the population to simply be a cnn or
msnbc population rather than a fox news
population is it better of course
my preference would be what i try to do
as a media diet which is i'm getting the
bulk of what
i believe is going on about the world
from news reporting agencies those that
have been shown to be more trustworthy
in a number of different studies and
evaluations associated press
reuters
many other examples from other countries
etc i want that to be the bulk of what
i'm understanding and then after that
i want to fill in with the perspectives
from some of these media outlets i mean
kovid's a great example
i wasn't taking my beliefs about kovid
from cnn norfox nor msnbc nor you know
whoever i'm i my view was let me look at
epidemiologists let me look at health
agencies let me look at interesting
researchers let me look at statistics
people people like nasim talib who would
take the data and say as a statistician
here is my interpretation and then let's
see how fox and cnn and others are
covering it russia ukraine is sort of
another example so this is a reassuring
article
but for me the solution isn't just
sitting people in front of msnbc or cnn
it's teaching them
that
msnbc and cnn should really be like at
the top of the information pyramid more
like the junk food and i include my show
in that as well notice that unlike you
know the reactionary right that says i'm
the only one telling you the truth
i should just be sort of a meeting place
where after we've all hopefully done our
homework we come together to share
opinions so interesting study we'll link
to it i encourage you to check it out
we've talked now for a while about how
if the american right
is really harping on the left is doing
this
we should really be considering whether
it is they themselves that are doing it
this is called projection this is
accusing others of doing that which you
are doing and when it comes to free
speech and cancel culture the right has
been making a living in some cases
literally making a living when it comes
to some of these right-wing media
outlets by saying the left wants to
cancel anybody they don't agree with and
the left wants to take away your free
speech we have a fascinating but
disturbing new report
about the book ban effort
and book ban efforts have hit their
highest level in at least 20 years and
it is not the left that is doing it it
is the right that is trying to do it so
we are going to look at this report from
the american library association it was
released earlier this week the report
found
over 700 challenges to library school
and university materials in 2021 this is
the most since at least 2000. the ala
has only been tracking such efforts
since the year 2000 so we can say it's
been at least 20 years but maybe more
axios goes on to say book bans have
risen substantially over the past year
as conservative groups have challenged
public school libraries and successfully
purged books from those libraries
generally about lgbtq issues which they
like to frame as you know inappropriate
gender and sexuality indoctrination and
books about people of color which they
often like to frame as teaching white
people to feel bad or critical race
theory or whatever the case may be
now there's a bunch of different
important elements to this that we need
to talk about first is again and i'm
going to say this a bunch of times this
is right-wingers
this is right-wingers doing this they
say they are for free speech but they
want to ban or challenge books
they say they are against canceling but
they want to cancel authors of books or
cancel a teacher's right or ability to
say here's the material i want to teach
with
and here's how i'm going to teach with
it they are the ones who are the experts
in education but it is random people say
no no you shouldn't be allowed to do
that
now
that is the projection and hypocrisy
piece oftentimes you know the people
most loudly talking about free speech
are the ones trying to limit it
when is it okay to ban books is it ever
okay to ban books
in this there is an important and
serious conversation to have in other
words are we saying
block certain books from being published
basically never there there is
essentially
never
uh we might be able to come up with a
couple of examples of when we are saying
it should be against the law for a
publisher to even publish certain books
are we saying
don't have certain books in certain
libraries okay well so let's now imagine
should there be pornography in an
elementary school library
no
should there be books that are
instruction manuals on how to make bombs
in elementary school libraries probably
not
but here we're already talking about age
restrictions that's very different than
a ban
and then there's the question of well
what about as part of class curriculum
should
eight-year-olds have certain materials
as part of their class curriculum and
there my idea is similar to my view on
responsible platforming sometimes i'll
interview a lunatic extremist uh we used
to interview the people from that
westboro baptist church and we would get
emails sometimes from people saying you
shouldn't have these people on because
you're platforming them and my response
was
responsible platforming means i've
determined
the views are worth exposing
and i feel equipped to make it clear
that the views are disgusting and that
was the difference between some of the
interviews i would do and some of the
ones that you would see elsewhere
similarly i i would apply the same kind
of test when it comes to school
curriculum
i understand saying you know
we don't want teachers teaching hitler's
mind conf
unless they are equipped to teach it
correctly and to teach it in a way that
makes it abundantly clear that these are
the disgusting views of a xenophobic
authoritarian maniac who had six million
jews killed
it starts to get more complicated
there's not one answer but the point
here is we are not saying
ban the book
we are not saying burn the book and i
remember in my high school history of
film class there were
discussions about
what movies is it okay for 14 year olds
to watch what level of gratuitous
violence and sexuality is okay for the
classroom doesn't mean
you know throw away what what at the
time were dvds doesn't mean don't allow
parents do i but there were questions
like what is appropriate for 14 year
olds to watch in school there's a fair
question is it too sexually explicit and
then we get to
the hypocritical aspect of the book bans
that they demand
and that can't be ignored because
they'll say oh this is too sexually
explicit but they're okay with
the sexuality that's in the bible which
is extreme and significant they say this
is too violent but they're okay with all
of the violence in the bible they make
exceptions there so the hypocrisy is a
major component
there is a real conversation to be had
here and in almost all cases we
shouldn't be banning books but we can't
even have that conversation with the
right because they just want them axed
they want to decide what teachers are
allowed to do they want to decide what
librarians are allowed to have in the
library and it's a bad faith
conversation from the ground up let me
know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at dpakman and let me know what
you think
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
i'm going to give you the headline and
tell you it really shouldn't be a
headline and that's really what we're
going to be focusing in on three
republicans will be voting for joe
biden's supreme court nominee judge
katanji brown jackson wow and it has
made dozens and dozens of headlines and
yet it really shouldn't even be a
headline the reason that this is a
headline is because supreme court
confirmations have become so
brazenly partisan
uh that it actually makes news when just
a few republicans are able to say wait a
second
in the senate we're supposed to
determine
is this a qualified individual to be on
the court and if he or she is then we
should vote to confirm it seems quaint
it seems almost antiquated it seems sort
of like the uh the the way of the past
because mostly it is and we have seen
hyper partisan word salad explanations
as to why many republicans are not going
to be voting to confirm judge jackson so
uh the associated press reporting
murkowski romney back jackson all but a
sure confirmation we already know about
maine republican senator susan collins
who said she would be voting for judge
jackson's confirmation and it just makes
perfect sense the associated press
reporting republican senators lisa
murkowski and mitt romney announced they
will vote to confirm judge katanji brown
jackson
giving president joe biden's nominee a
burst of bipartisan support and all but
assuring she'll become the first black
female justice
uh republican susan collins announced
last week she would back jackson noting
her stellar qualifications all three
republicans said they did not expect to
agree with all of judge jackson's
decisions but they found her extremely
well qualified romney romney said
jackson more than meets the standard of
intelligence of excellence and integrity
murkowski said she will bring to the
supreme court a range of experience from
the courtroom that few can match given
her background in litigation so she is
going to be confirmed and she should be
confirmed because the truth is she is
arguably as qualified as any of the nine
justices currently on the court i've
referred to this document before that
was put together which looks at the
experience and qualifications of the
nine justices currently on the court as
well as as judge jackson's and as you
can see judge jackson if you're if
you're looking
judge jackson is the only the only of
the what what we're talking about 10
people the nine on the court plus her
who has this wide range of experience
she has public high school education
which you can argue uh gives a
particular perspective that is useful
for a justice to have she has the ivy
league law school education as well
she was a supreme court clerk
she is
the only of the nine plus one justices
and judge to be a public defender she is
the only other than judge sotomayor to
have been a district judge she's the
only one
other than judge breyer to have been on
a sentencing commission and of course
serving as well on uh as a judge on the
court of appeals and what's both funny
and kind of disheartening to see
is that many republicans don't even
really seem to know why they aren't
voting for her confirmation or at least
they're not willing to say it and maybe
that's the more important thing
earlier this week i played a clip for
you of republican senator roy blunt he
was asked by george stephanopoulos are
you going to support her and he said no
i'm not and when he was asked why he
went on like a 90-second word salad that
didn't make any sense something about
judicial philosophy that was completely
unintelligible
we have other examples of this here is
lindsey graham recently saying
he is not going to be voting to confirm
judge jackson but she's very qualified
and smart and seems to meet all the
requirements judge jackson has got a lot
to be proud of she's accomplished a lot
in her life she's a good person i'm sure
she's a great mother and
a very gifted
person she's
fought hard to be where she's at in life
i'll vote no i'm the first first time
i've ever voted against any supreme
court nominee here's another example of
lindsey graham as well
i find judge jackson's to be a person of
exceptionally good character respected
by our peers and someone who has worked
hard to achieve her current position
however her record is overwhelming
in its lack of a steady judicial
philosophy and a tendency to achieve
outcomes in spite of what the law
requires our common sense would dictate
after a thorough review of judge
jackson's record and information gained
at the hearing from an evasive witness
i now know why judge jackson was the
favorite of the radical left and i will
vote no so
it's basically a meaningless statement
her judicial philosophy isn't steady in
its record now some of you have been
writing to me saying david you know why
they're not voting for her but they
can't say it they're not voting for her
because she's black now i don't have
evidence that that's the case
what it does seem to me
is that her identity meaning
a black woman nominated by a democrat
named katanji
those characteristics
are making republicans
look at her record
in a different way than they would if
this was someone nominated by donald
trump with a different identity and you
don't have to look much further than for
example lindsey lindsey graham's vote
in favor of her being appointed to the
court of appeals where she currently
sits lindsey graham is not the only
republican who has said many times well
we
she's very qualified
for other positions and when they're
asked about this what you'll often hear
from them is they'll say well
it's a different standard now because
this is the highest court of the land
someone that would be qualified for a
lower court wouldn't necessarily be
qualified for the highest court in the
land that's totally plausible it's at
least theoretically an acceptable
differentiation
they just aren't able to articulate
exactly what they mean and it's very
transparently pathetic now one other
note on mitt romney supporting her
mitt romney is a less crazy republican
there's no doubt of that not saying i
love romney not saying i want romney to
be the president of the united states
but mitt romney is a far less crazy
republican than many of these other
people at the same time
we shouldn't ignore the idea
that maybe romney is trying to just kind
of revive
the ma the possibility that he could run
for president in the future although i
still don't think that he has plans to
do that he said before it's not
something he intends to get back in but
maybe mitt romney for that or other
reasons wants to kind of rehabilitate
his reputation i don't know now in the
meantime
the cuckoo for coco puffs or the um
what would we call
anyway the wacky wing of the the trump
wing of the republican party
they are coming up with wild attacks on
the three republicans that will be
supporting judge jackson including
marjorie taylor greene tweeting
murkowski collins and romney
are
pro-pedophile because they plan to
support judge katanji brown jackson
that's obviously
an absurd interpretation the question is
is she qualified
the answer is yes she is the outcome if
you put these inputs into a computer and
you calculate the outcome should be uh
we're going to vote to confirm her and
so far we know about three republicans
that will
uh i i hate to go back to our story of
projection but i sort of have to
one of the big stories that republicans
have been telling for a long time now is
democrats are going to commit fraud when
it comes to the election democrats are
going to send people out to vote twice
democrats are going to send out uh
people to vote in the names of those who
have died they're going to do all these
different things and of course none of
it happened but we now have yet another
example
of a republican who did just that
and it's a trump staffer a former trump
staffer who is running for the new
hampshire house
voted in two states in 2016. we're going
to go through it but then it's also an
important opportunity to clarify
things that are actually against the law
versus things that are really no big
deal that republicans still say are
against the law
associated press reports trump aide
seeking new hampshire house seat
voted in two states in 2016. a former
trump administration official now
running for congress in new hampshire
voted twice during the 2016 primary
election season potent potentially
violating federal voting law
and of course leaving him at odds with
the republican party's focus on
so-called election integrity we're
talking about matt mowers or mowers a
leading republican primary candidate who
wants to upset
unseat rather democratic rep chris
pappas
matt mowers cast an absentee ballot in
new hampshire's 2016 presidential
primary according to voting records at
the time he was the director of former
new jersey governor chris christie's
presidential campaign
four months later chris christie was
gone and mowers cast another ballot in
the new jersey republican presidential
primary using his
parents address to re-register in his
home state
is this against the law it appears to be
legal experts say his actions could
violate a federal law that prohibits
more voting more than once in any
general
special or primary election that
includes casting a ballot in separate
jurisdictions so there are two or three
different stories here first of all when
republicans go on and on about voter
fraud
they want to make it seem like they're
accusing the other side they seem to
have been describing their own actions
it's almost like these republican
allegations end up being confessions oh
no you can't vote for hillary because
she won't be trustworthy with classified
information and she had a private email
server
we know how that turned out and it's the
exact same thing here but what i really
want to focus in on because listen it
they we keep catching these republicans
doing this stuff it's almost not even
news that they keep getting caught doing
this stuff mark meadows
uh uh voting registered in two states
all these different things
important reminder
just because the right says something is
illegal
doesn't mean it is and let me give you
some examples
um
being registered
in two different states
is not against the law as long as you
don't vote in two different states what
malwares did appears to be illegal but
it is not uncommon that people live in
one state and are registered there
and then after the primary and before
the general they move to a different
state
and then they register there and they
legally vote as long as you didn't vote
in both states just being registered in
two places is not against the law
and uh
we have to remember that secondly they
say well dead people voted tons of dead
people voted there's no evidence of that
but what sometimes happens is somebody
was alive
you vote by mail absentee and then you
die before the date of the general
election
that's not against the law you haven't
done anything wrong you were alive when
you voted it becomes a clerical issue
another example people voted twice
oftentimes republicans will find that
someone was registered in two places and
they will say this person voted twice as
long as you didn't actually vote twice
you're not doing anything wrong it's a
clerical issue that the old place where
you lived hasn't deregistered you it's
important to remember the mass scale
stuff they claim is happening isn't
happening but a lot of the things that
happen anecdotally
are not actually against the law
do they actually care that people
understand that of course not of course
not uh make sure you are following us on
instagram at david pakman show we'll
take a quick break and be back after
this with much much more
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show i have a great example
for you today of techniques to counter
propaganda many times uh people will ask
how is it best to react
when someone asserts this or says that
and you know that their reason for
bringing it up is a bad faith reason or
the premise is wrong or whatever the
case may be so we're going to talk about
this today
using an example from fox news reporter
peter ducey who's always trying to
make himself look i guess big and strong
and like a real reporter and like a guy
who asks important questions
and the technique here is ask for
examples when you are given a premise
and you know
that the premise is shaky or it's being
used to make a point that doesn't
actually follow the first thing is make
them defend the premise don't just
accept it and fox's peter ducey
asked white house press secretary jen
saki about the don't say gay bill from
florida
and the question he asked was
does the white house support
teaching kids younger than kindergarten
sex education or gender education you
know whatever the case may be and jen
saki smartly says
do you even have examples of when that's
being done because if you don't you're
really just saying
will biden denounce something that's not
even going on and that's what we would
define as a pointless question to answer
so let's look at the clip and then we're
going to talk about it so if you guys
oppose this law that bans classroom
instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k through 3. does the white house
support that kind of classroom
instruction before kindergarten do you
have examples of schools in florida that
are teaching kindergarteners about sex
education i'm just asking for the
president i think that's a i think
that's a relevant question because i
think this is a politically charged
harsh law that is putting
parents and lgbtq plus kids in a very
difficult uh a heartbreaking
circumstance and so i actually think
that's a pretty relevant question so
this is a really good technique uh and
i'm gonna talk about it a little more in
a second so first of all understand that
what steve ducey uh peter ducey brings
up
it's it's just not happening it's not
happening um uh first of all when we
talk about sexual orientation
instruction the don't say gay bill is
about in k through three
and ducey goes further by saying before
k through three so you talking about day
care you're talking about infants being
given sex education or whatever i looked
for a while and i found no i don't i
didn't even find any allegations that it
was happening now had i found
allegations i would have tried to find
proof i haven't even found allegations
that kids younger than kindergarten are
being taught this type of material um
and it's just uh there's just no
evidence that it's going on
um so
jen saki is smart here and um the
real reasons to oppose the bill of
course are that it's outrageously
homophobic in its underpinnings it's
absurdly transphobic
it's obviously a double standard because
when it says you can't talk about gender
you can't talk about romantic
relationships all these different things
if it were applied
fairly and consistently
a heterosexual teacher shouldn't even
really be allowed to talk about her
husband or his wife if it is a man but
of course the point is not actually to
apply it equally do you think anyone is
going i mean maybe to try to make a
political point it'll happen but do you
think that if the parents of a first
grader here that mrs smith talked about
her husband mr smith they're going to
show up and say they're violating the
the bill they're violating the bill no
of course not because the whole point of
it is fundamentally homophobic and
transphobic uh but the the bad faith
piece is
saying
do you favor
the thing that the bill bans or do you
favor this thing
that the bill may be banned but isn't
even actually happening and this is a
common technique that they like to use
this came up when i was interviewed
remember this guy jessie lee peterson a
couple years ago i was out in los
angeles for uh politicon and jesse lee
peterson invited me to
his studio
for an interview and he started talking
to me about obama being socialist and
making everything socialist and i took
the exact same approach here that jen
saki took which is to say
what socialist things did obama do or
even try to do and it imploded
i would say it imploded in humiliating
fashion for jesse i don't know that he's
capable of actually feeling humiliated
so it should have but here's a reminder
of how that all went down but so here
let me ask you about this
i'm not a socialist myself i'm a social
just to be clear i'm i don't i'm not
advocating for social media
i don't know that many actual socialists
like who would
who where's the big desire for the us to
become socialist if you look at the
democratic party there's almost no
socialists in the democracy
communist party now what's one that's
one socialist idea from the democratic
party um uh socialized healthcare no
that's a social social democracy program
no
is denmark socialist and if you notice
that barack obama
the father messiah you know he used to
follow the messiah right
i don't know anything about that well
beat mama michelle uh he tried to turn
america into a socialist society what's
one example of a socialist policy that
he had uh socialized healthcare he
didn't do that he did for-profit
obamacare taking care of everybody how
so by getting rid of jobs many people
mostly he took care of people about
getting full-time jobs and they had to
work two part-time jobs in order to
survive just so you don't even
understand the talking points the rest
stopped working and just went and
depended on and relied on the government
free obama phones
that's socialist socialism so how can
you
want to ask a real question
i'm asking you a real question obama
phones are not socialism no i'll answer
your question so it's a good technique
uh ducey is a clown
he's unable to provide even a single
example because there are none no one is
sitting no one sitting in pre-k
teaching sex education or about
transgender people or what
it's just not happening and once again
this is one of those things where
they're doing it to
judge katanji brown jackson as well
there is of course no evidence that
judge jackson
likes pedophilia
supports it
defends it but they are taking out of
however many sentences she's given
some cases where the sentence fell short
of the maximum or of what the
prosecution wanted and using that as
evidence that she must be in favor of
this thing she just must be right i mean
she must she must defend the pedophiles
or the sex uh uh child sexual predators
or whoever the case may be um it's
non-existent
understand the technique use the
technique hey this is kind of
interesting here's another of these very
few examples where the former president
donald trump
seems to concede that he did lose the
2020 election although he kind of does
it with a caveat there's a very
interesting interview
in the atlantic and it's written about
in the guardian and we're going to link
to both there's the atlantic article
what i learned when trump tried to
correct the record by julian selizer
this is from a couple days ago and then
there's also an interesting article uh
in in the guardian as well i didn't win
the election trump admits defeat in
session with historians trump also said
iran china and south korea were happy
biden won
adding that the election was rigged and
lost
donald trump has admitted he did not win
the 2020 election i didn't win the
election he said
the admission came in a video interview
with a panel of historians convened by
julian selizer a princeton professor and
editor of the presidency of donald trump
the interview was published earlier this
week by the atlantic
describing his attempts to make south
korea pay more for u.s military
assistance trump said moon jae-in the
south korean president was among the
happiest world leaders after the 2020
election put joe biden in the white
house by not winning the election trump
said he was the happiest man i would say
in order china was no
iran was the happiest
uh trump also said the election was
rigged and lost
trump's refusal to accept defeat by
biden provoked attempts to overturn
results in key states as we know
trump was impeached a second time
trump remains free to run for the white
house again in 2024 which he has
repeatedly hinted he would do writing
for the atlantic zelizer said trump was
the one who had decided to reach out to
a group of professional historians so
that we produce an accurate book an
accurate book
trump seemed to want the approval of
historians without any understanding of
how historians gather evidence
or render judgments so it's always with
a caveat it's always with a caveat and
at this point we understand there is
this double standard right if you won
how could you run again but i guess it's
you can't serve
more than two terms so even though he
won 2020 he can run again but he didn't
win because it was rigged and so he lost
but he should have won it it's this
endless loop of logic what i think is um
really interesting about this
is that trump is more regularly now
saying things like it was lost it was
rigged but we we did lose to some degree
and
for a lot of people on the right who are
committed to this
as an ideology they're not committed to
it as a fact we've said before that for
some trumpists they literally believe
trump won and we've seen interviews with
them at trump rallies they they seem
genuine when they say trump really won
it was stolen trump actually won he got
more votes in more states he had more
electoral votes he won
for other trumpists
it's what you say to show
that you're on the right team that
you're still on the team and they may
not literally believe that donald trump
got more votes should have been
president and the election was stolen
but you say it to signal an allegiance
to donald trump and i've spoken before
about how
for many of these folks they see
themselves
as being in a war and they see it sort
of like a holy war and when you're at
war
you sort of say or do what you have to
do
even if it's not honest because of it
being a means to an end and that listen
even if we take some casualties it's
okay
because it's a necessary war or whatever
the case may be
in some sense that is what this
statement trump won has become for many
of them and even though trump has
increasingly said okay well i lost but
it was rigged or whatever
remember when we didn't find weapons of
mass destruction in iraq
despite george w bush and the late colin
powell and others telling us they're
there they weren't there we didn't find
them and even after that was an
undeniable fact many bush supporters
kept saying we did find them some of
them probably thought that we did much
like now some trumpists probably believe
trump did win but on the other hand for
some of them it was just something that
you say and this is something that it's
a phenomena that exists in politics
that's bigger than trump the particular
lies right now are associated with trump
but it's no surprise people do this for
you can call it cognitive dissonance
uh you can call it magical thinking
there's a lot of different things that
you can call it but don't expect it to
go away even if trump more consistently
concedes that he did lose it wasn't fair
but he did lose as he recently did once
again follow us on social media interact
with the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's start with a reminder uh
that we may need we may not need just a
reminder that the one group that seems
to continually garner the loyalty of
this
kind of like neo-ra reactionary right
i've continued to struggle with how we
should refer to sort of like trumpists
because they're they're not conservative
they're not neocons
but they are reactionary and they're
smitten with dictators and brutal
regimes and the one real loyalty that
seems to be unbending and unchanging is
to authoritarians in a new interview on
real america's voice which is rapidly
becoming one of the most unhinged
reactionary fact-free media outlets out
there uh donald trump was bemoaning
the poor treatment
of saudi arabia
by the united states one of the biggest
violators of human rights in the world
we've treated them poorly
says donald trump in this interview take
a listen to this oh yeah you you kind of
stayed with them through the khashoggi
thing you said hey it's horrible but
it's not going to jeopardize a 70-year
relationship we have now they meet with
russia now they're buying uh they're
selling them oil and they're taking uh
robles trying to get rid of the
petrodollar
do you feel that they've uh the that ksa
has stabbed us in the back
so i think this i think they've been
treated very badly by our country
they don't want to see the iran nuclear
deal that's a catastrophe i ended it
we were very very good with saudi arabia
and all of them they were buying
massive amounts of our military
equipment and everything else
this really is beyond the pale
um and understand that they're all in on
it there are even even the question from
the reporter
already is framed to give a very
particular perspective the khashoggi
thing the kachoji khashoggi thing
it's
it's horrible but you know our
relationship over oil and weapons at
least
they're all saying it like it is right i
mean okay yes
it was international premeditated murder
at the direction of the saudi royal
family in cold blood
of a member of the media planned well in
advance people flown in with bone saws
okay yeah i mean the khashoggi thing but
oil
weapons come on guys and it's really
kind of emblematic of how they see this
and we shouldn't forget that it's you
know this is not i'm not drawing a
parallel
between the khashoggi thing which was
one guy getting killed and 911. these
are two different things but it's the
type of minimization
proportional minimization which would be
like referring to 911 as
we have lots of buildings in this
country they knocked down two they
knocked down two buildings but we've had
this relationship for decades the oil
and the arms and we want the cheap gas
and by the way it's not not working out
keeping it super cheap we have to accept
the political reality that trump and his
voting block
their main
you know they're like chameleons where i
guess we we don't hate gay people or
maybe we do or we're not too concerned
with trans people but now all of a
sudden we are and maybe we uh we we
don't want the government involved in
health care unless trump's going to give
us some even better version of obamacare
where the government will be more it's
all malleable like putty really crappy
putty i should say
but the one thing that doesn't change is
they're just smitten with the autocrats
any opportunity to defend or minimize
the
ills committed by
autocrats and dictators and human rights
violators that they will do that has not
changed and when you think of all of
trump's different unchanging uh
loyalties
the only ones i can find are to the
autocrats uh and to people who line
trump's pockets and of course remember
that there are saudis that own trump
buildings floors condos whatever
different different pieces of trump
properties i believe
the 45th floor of trump tower and the
like it's not even really america first
it's really trump first and america
first
as ugly as is the history of america
first
it's almost a distraction where trump
says to his base america first
they love it and they don't realize that
it's actually trump first at the end of
the day so just another one of these
examples trump has abandoned his
supporters he'll abandon republicans as
soon as they say well i didn't like this
one thing trump did oh that's a rhino
he'll abandon all of them but he
continues to be smitten with the
autocrats and that doesn't seem to
change
i have another one of these
kind of dystopian
stories about my interactions with the
medical system many of you will remember
my infamous 35 40 000 appendectomy from
a couple of years back i have a new one
guys i had a freckle removed
and we're talking about twenty three
hundred dollars so here's what what went
on
um i had i have various freckles and
moles like many people do i'm not going
to list where every single one of them
is but
all sorts of different places
and i had one on my abdomen
it just looked a little bit different it
had a little bit of a glow around it
um it had like a little black dot in
what was otherwise about okay well
listen i don't need to describe to you
the the
exact the dermatological characteristics
but i said
uh i'm going to have this one looked at
so i went to my dermatologist and i said
to him sir what do you think and he
looked at it and he said it's probably
fine let's put it under a black light
i forget what that's called but he did
that he said the black light stuff it it
also seems fine but you know we can't
really be sure unless
we do a biopsy do you think you want a
biopsy and i said oh boy i don't know i
did not big on medical procedures what's
the biopsy he says little shot of uh
numbing
and then i take this thing called a uh
biopsy punch looks like a hole punch and
uh we'll just punch out a two millimeter
little circle we'll send it out to be
looked at i said do you think medically
it's appropriate he said listen my view
is
when your attention goes to a particular
freckle or mole
it might be for a reason
so
we'll get information let's do it i said
fine numb me up give me the whole thing
we did it
i have a i have pretty crappy insurance
because as a self-employed individual
i'm in the private market private market
plans are just terrible i pay 543
dollars a month
and i still have a 60 copay for
specialists and i still have a 2 000
deductible for um
analysis of any kind
so
he does the biopsy and i hear back it's
benign it's benign it's nothing let's
just see if it comes back we'll keep an
eye on it but it's benign no need to
worry great well i i know i'm going to
get a bill for my 60
copay
first bill comes in and i'm putting
these up on the screen for you guys
first bill
is for 631
dollars whoa wait hold on
where did this come from well
i had in my office visit so they charged
for that i had the biopsy that was 204
dollars okay
and then there was the lab pathology
that needed to be done you can't just do
the biopsy you've got to study the
biopsy so that's 100 another 159 bucks
so now it's 6 31.
my insurance covered about half
leaving 300 for me so i've got my 60
copay but some of this stuff
is not part of the office visit it's
extra
so i owed 307
and i thought okay well that's not that
bad
but wait a second what about the
facility i mean guys they've got to keep
the lights on the temperature was
pleasant in the room
so i've got to pay for the facility
but also i need to pay for the procedure
itself
i don't even know what i mean i thought
i already did so that's another
eleven hundred fifty dollars but not to
worry
my insurance company has covered five
hundred and ten dollars leaving only
another six thirty nine for me
now you want to know the sick reality
before i total all of this up for you
guys
part of what the insurance covered
they didn't actually pay
it's that my insurance negotiated a
discount
so even though it shows up that my
insurance covered five hundred and ten
dollars of one piece and three hundred
and twenty dollars of the other piece
they didn't really cover eight hundred
dollars
uh more than half of that was they thank
god they did this for me aren't they
nice they negotiated a discount
with my insurance company so at the end
of the day
a five-minute biopsy
ends up with me owing for the month
fourteen hundred and eighty nine dollars
it's i'm already in for 543 on my health
insurance
and then i owe another
940
for the biopsy am i better off not
having insurance is a really fair
question there there's this whole cycle
that happens and we've talked about the
broken nature of this system not
everybody pays
and insurance companies negotiate
discounts so this creates a race to the
bottom really a race to the top where
the providers keep bumping up
the prices that they build to insurance
knowing that insurance is going to come
to them and say we don't want to pay
that much we want to pay less so give us
a discount and then knowing that some
people won't have insurance and they'll
end up not paying at all and they'll
have to write off some of that so they
have to raise the price even more to
account for some people aren't going to
pay maybe they really should only be
charging 300 for this total but between
insurance and medical billing and
overhead and negotiated discounts it
goes up up up up
so at the end of the day
if i didn't even have insurance it's
conceivable that i could have gone to
them and said guys
do you have a cash price because i have
no insurance
i would have saved my 540 a month in
premium and maybe they would have said
we will accept x or we will accept y or
some some smaller amount obviously the
risk with that is if you have something
really major two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars five hundred thousand
dollars you know icu stays really really
bad uh even the cash discount is not
going to be affordable so just another
this is not unique this is a very small
thing i know many of you in the audience
have emailed sengu you've got hundreds
of thousands of dollars a month in bills
because you're on expensive medications
or require expensive treatments etc
i am just giving you a tiny little
example this was the smallest skin
biopsy that could be done the two
millimeter they call it the little boy
it wasn't the you don't you don't want
to see the big boy when they have to do
the big boy um and we're talking about
total
2300
of which i end up paying
nine something
plus my health insurance premium it's
not a sustainable system
and by the way
i can afford this
right at the end of the day
this 950 i can afford it it's painful
yeah i mean it's frustrating but i can
afford it
40 of the country
can't meet an unexpected 400 expense
without
going into debt
i went in thinking i have a 60 copay
when there the doctor says the
appropriate thing
is to do a biopsy but i'm going to say
no and all of a sudden i come out owing
9.50
in addition to my health insurance
premium it's a crazy system and i know
that i will get emails from people
around the country saying around the
world rather saying
david that system in the u.s is nuts we
know it's nuts trust me we know it's
nuts we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
one of our viewers correctly identified
a technique
that yesterday's guest darlene swaffer
used or the day before yesterday's guest
darlene swaffer used when i would ask
her questions take a listen
hello david uh i really enjoyed
listening to your interview with
congressional candidate diane swapper
darlene i wanted to provide a piece of
commentary as to when you were asking
for questions during the interview i
noticed that almost every single
question that you asked her she repeated
it in full out loud before beginning to
deliver her answer
as a person who is obsessed with
criminal psychology and other forms of
psychology
it probably doesn't come as a shock to
you or many of your viewers this is a
stalling tech week i believe a lot of
the questions that you asked her she had
really no responses
for
and was formulating on the fly
you know there is a possibility she was
trying to conceal something um
you know being that sometimes that is a
behavior uh that lends itself towards
guilt as a liar might need more time to
stall for an answer but i think she was
just woefully uh ill-informed about a
lot of the topics that you discussed so
thank you so much for bringing us such a
uh yeah and uh she was uninformed and
unprepared and sometimes i mean again as
i said before one of the questions i
asked darlene swaffer the trumpet
candidate was who's the current
president
that's like a concussion brain injury
stroke protocol question
and she couldn't answer she couldn't
answer it and you have correctly
identified a common technique which is
stalling she did a couple other things
which is at any time you can say it's
not a question i want to delve into i i
don't want to say i don't want to give
an answer
because it's controversial in nature or
whatever the case may be and what's wild
is these very same people don't accept
that type of answer from a supreme court
nominee well that could come before the
court so i don't want to answer it but
when i just say who's the president they
think that that's a legitimate answer
it's wild it is wild and completely
bonkers
don't miss today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
we will see you then